ah
y
cuánto cuesta tener arte y cultura en
sus vidas cuánto cuánto cuesta alguna
idea
no mucho poquito
jajaja
cuánto cuesta tener literatura en
nuestras vidas
nada
cine en nuestras vidas
sabía que ir al cine o sea ir al cine de
las marcas conocidas es consumir arte lo
sabía
las películas sean del género que sean
son arte y al momento de ir al cine no
estamos consumiendo y además nos está
sirviendo a nuestra vida
les quiero contar una historia había una
vez un niño pequeño que cuando le tocó
entrar a la primaria se topa con un
mundo totalmente diferente no sé cómo
les haya pasado a ustedes no sé si
puedan hacer un poquito de memoria
cuando llegas a la primaria o cuando
llegas por primera vez al centro escolar
lo que es no el cambio de mundo y las
cosas a las que te enfrentas y luego si
resulta que te sales del molde
empieza lo que ahora se llama pues acoso
escolar no que le ponen el nombre muy
bonito pero también también le dicen
bullying bueno pues resulta que eso
empezó a suceder y empezó a subir de
todo y empieza pues a batallar mucho
porque además en la en la familia pues
yo creo que no hay familias perfectas
pero hay un dicho que dice que nadie
sabe lo que pesa el morral así sea en mi
rancho nadie sabe lo que pesa el morral
más el que lo va cargando solamente esa
persona sabe lo que está pasando ahí no
entonces había pues la escuela problemas
en la familia el lugar donde vivía pues
era un lugar chico entonces pues ya se
imaginarán también pues las cuestiones
ahí con la gente dish no dicen pueblo
chico infierno grande entonces había
varios factores que luego cuando estás
creciendo cuando eres un niño que estás
en
en plena definición de quién eres y
hacia dónde vas pues te puede llegar a
afectar muchísimo y si no cuentas con la
asesoría o por la línea conductual
necesaria
te puedes perder en el camino pero hubo
algo que a ese niño le ocurrió
ustedes imagina quién era ese niño
quien haga
pues si no me gusta ponerme ejemplo pero
híjole
a mí me pasó
entonces
yo vivía en un pueblito muy chiquito yo
nací en un pueblito muy chiquito de
nuevo léon un pueblo en las montañas y
arriba más arriba y más montañas
entonces imagínense el paisaje y luego
el pueblo a la mitad está dividido por
la vegetación de este lado es como puro
bosque y del otro lado es muy seco muy
desértico entonces un paisaje bellísimo
hermoso pero desgraciadamente pues no
había mucho espacio para que una persona
en mi caso fuera feliz y tuviera esa
convivencia armónica con el medio
ambiente que allí había entonces que
pasó pues mi mamá tengo tengo recuerdos
muy muy claros de mi mamá que nunca se
me van a olvidar mi mamá como era madre
soltera o es madre soltera durante el
día pues tiene que trabajar llegaba la
tarde y llegaba y hacía unos parajes
porque ya se habían metido las gallinas
de la vecina al patio y se había comido
sus macetas o sus plantas
y luego se enojaba porque tampoco le
gustaban los perros ahora yo adoro los
perros pero a ella no le gusta entonces
se metían los perros de las vecinas
porque son es un pueblito entonces
imagínense no sé si conozcan los
pueblitos no la gente es es muy muy
diferente porque pues no hay esas
divisiones la convivencia es muy muy
diferente puedes cruzar de un terreno a
otro sin tanto problema entonces bueno
imagínense los animales pues más
entonces llegaba la tarde buena decía
sus corajes y todo pero lo después ya
cenábamos se ponía a ver el noticiero de
la noche sacaba su ganchillo de sus
agujas de ganchillo para empezar a tejer
mientras del noticiero se ponía sus
lentes de bifocales si sabes lo que son
dijo acá la verdad
entonces empezar a tejer y de ratos se
cansaba de eso y agarrar un libro y ese
si le daba un buen rato hasta que ya
tenía mucho sueño o a veces veía
noticiero y luego se iba a la cama y
empezaba a leer el libro hasta que ya le
ganaba el sueño y era un hábito diario
que nunca nunca se va a olvidarse tengo
muy grabadas esas escenas de mi mamá
leyendo y entonces empiezo yo también a
agarrar los libros porque pues probó en
la casa tenemos libros me imagino que en
sus casas tienen libros a veces pues
tenemos de adorno no me van a dejar
mentir bueno hay que agarrarlos empezar
a empezar a hojear los de perdido y
luego se van a ir enamorando entonces yo
empiezo a agarrar los libros que había
ahí algunos no eran muy adecuados pero
bueno ya vas viendo ahí qué libros son
los que te gustan más o qué libros si
les entiende si a qué libros no algunos
que empecé a leer en aquel entonces pues
no les entendía ahora los releer los
releo ya
un poco más grande ya les entiendo
verdad
y así fue como me empecé a encontrar con
la literatura luego mi hermana quien
también es una persona ejemplar para mí
la considero como mi segunda madre para
trabajar en aquel entonces en la
biblioteca municipal y pues así me
generan en donde estaba yo todas las
tardes me la pasaba en la biblioteca y
como ella era la jefa y pues me dejaba
estar todo el rato podía llevar con los
libros a la casa y luego obviamente los
regresaba
podía dibujar lo que ahí veía se había
un mundo de posibilidades a mi alcance
con los libros
en ese entonces pues yo no me daba
cuenta todavía sino que lo que pasó fue
que empiezo a empiezo a leer ya leer ya
leer y empiezo a darme cuenta que pues
hay infinidad infinidad de posibilidades
puedes cambiar tu perspectiva puedes
mejorar tu entorno a partir de ti mismo
puedes mejorar lo que tanto te afecta
si tú empiezas
a sembrar en ti cosas positivas y cosas
buenas así fue como me encontré con la
literatura y precisamente por eso ahora
me dedico a promover en mis tiempos
libres la lectura pero no solamente la
lectura porque luego después me fui
encontrando con otras artes con que era
algo que ya estaba en el destino no sé
por qué luego me encontré con la
fotografía con la danza con el teatro
con diversas manifestaciones culturales
no quiere decir que yo me haya metido a
hacer teatro o actuar o que yo me haya
metido a tomar fotos buenos hitos y tomó
fotos porque en mi carrera yo soy
periodista pues te enseñan a tomar fotos
y aparte pensar es algo que ya traes no
quieres registrar la realidad siempre y
siempre estás buscando la nota y
capturar la fotografía bueno ahí el
medio le hacemos
entonces me voy dando cuenta que había
todo este mundo de posibilidades
no incursión en ella sino que aprendí a
apreciar las y disfrutarlas analizarlas
a que fueran parte de mi vida
y que te das cuenta que esas cosas
artísticas culturales pueden influir de
forma positiva en ti y en tu realidad
hay algunas estadísticas por parte de la
encuesta nacional de lectura en el 2012
aquí les traigo para no para no echar
las mentiras las voy a leer la encuesta
perdón la encuesta de consumo cultural
es en 2012 es una de las referencias más
cercanas que tenemos nos dice que entre
todos los datos que arroja esta encuesta
y que se hace en todo el país nos dice
que 4 de 10 personas en todo méxico de
cada 4 de cada 10 han asistido por lo
menos una vez en su vida a una feria oa
un festival o sea imagínense menos de la
mitad de las personas han tenido el
privilegio de acudir a un evento incluso
un evento como estos
es bueno yo lo considero muy poquito
porque además muchos de los eventos
culturales son gratuitos preferimos ir a
pagar a un evento que solamente nos va a
entretener un ratito y pagamos miles de
pesos que ir a una feria del libro son
gratis claro los libros están en venta
pero no se comparan con un boleto de
otra cosa no además ahí hay ferias que
tienen los libros muy baratos
cuatro de cada diez han asistido a un
festival de cine o han asistido a un
festival cultural o han asistido a un
encuentro de escritores se hacen
encuentros de escritores y muchos son
con personajes de las localidades o sea
es bueno saber que hay gente haciendo
arte y cultura generando arte y cultura
y promoviéndola en las comunidades
también otro dato importante que les
quiero compartir la encuesta nacional de
lectura nos dice que
selene 2.9 libros por persona al año o
sea imagínense una persona como tú como
yo leemos en un año ni siquiera tres
libros nos quedamos abajito
la verdad me parece muy poquito no les
parece poco a ustedes
sí no o sea imagínense el año tiene 12
meses estaría padre que leyéramos un
libro por mes le diríamos 12 libros al
año
pero no lo hacemos y luego resulta que
hay personas que si leen o leemos pero
leemos porque nos lo encargaron no en la
universidad en la maestría como yo que
estoy haciendo maestría ahora estoy
leyendo más que nunca
no estoy presentando obligando pero está
padre
porque te lo encargan en la primaria
porque te lo encargan pero esa lectura
no es lo mismo que tú te identifiques
con un libro que te conectes con ese
libro que lo abras y que digas es que ya
quiero ya quiero saber de qué se trata
ya quiero saber que sigue en el donde
dejé el separador ya quiero continuar
ese es el personaje es como yo la
protagonista el protagonista y eso es
muy valioso para nosotros porque nos
alimenta el espíritu qué pasa con el
resto de las artes bueno luego me
encontré también con el cine y ahora
ando muy metido en cosas de cine no
haciéndolo como les dije ahorita sino
promoviendo como viendo cosas de arte y
cultura
con el cine hay en el pueblito donde yo
nací y pues no había cine no había gente
ni haciendo cine ni ni complejos
cinematográficos pero como me cree muy
joven a la ciudad de monterrey para
estudiar la carrera periodismo que era
lo que yo siempre había querido hacer
siempre había querido ser un periodista
voy a monterrey y bueno allí hay muchos
cines y luego resulta que me doy cuenta
que los miércoles está más gratis
entonces pues ya como estudiaba
trabajaba pues los miércoles para mí
eran sagrados y los pedía y en el
trabajo los miércoles ni me los toquen
yo voy a ir a tiene luego te das cuenta
que hay otras opciones que la cineteca
que los cineclubes que las funciones en
los barrios y luego ahora ya las
plataformas que tenemos al alcance de
todas y todos en las casas que son
magníficas también porque es una
variedad de opciones nada más ahí la
cuestión es tener un sentido crítico
para saber cuál si y cuál no cuál nos va
a entretener y cuál nos va a dejar algo
para nuestra vida
qué pasa con la difusión del cine aquí
en nuestro país
el anuario del imcine en el instituto
mexicano de la cinematografía nos dice
que el año pasado porque el anuario de
este año todavía no sale se publicaba a
principios del siguiente año nos dice
que hay 664 cineclubes en todo méxico
y hay 155 festivales de cine aquí el
festival de cine saber en qué fechas
en aguascalientes no hay bueno hay que
organizarlo
si hay o no hay
a festival cultural
no hay ok pues hay que hacerlo
les aseguro lo que quieran les apuesto
que aquí hay gente haciendo cine y
ustedes no saben que esa gente está
retratando su realidad la realidad de
aguascalientes de jesús maría en cine
para verla en la pantalla grande
qué belleza poder verlo en una pantalla
está como está
la realidad de aguascalientes y aparte
con el toque del director o la directora
que es lo que cuenta muchísimo
bueno también el 2018 hubo 320 millones
de personas asistiendo a cines aquí en
nuestro país de los cuales solamente el
30 millones o sea una cantidad bajísima
fue la que fue a ver cine mexicano
entonces también ahí es un tema
pendiente que tenemos no hay que hay que
darle el valor que tiene a nuestro cine
mexicano regresando un poquito las
cifras de los cineclubes que yo les
decía en 664 en todo méxico y 155
festivales lo podemos comparar con los
complejos cinematográficos comerciales
de las dos marcas más conocidas que
ustedes ya conocen hay 886 complejos
entonces no andamos tan mal si hay
opciones para poder
tener esta variedad de opciones
culturales cinematográficas que nos
puedan ayudar a alimentar nuestra vida
ahora que andamos en esta dinámica de
llevar círculos de lectura cuentacuentos
a las primarias a las secundarias
lectura en secundarias ahora que tenemos
esta cuestión de los cineclubes de
barrio las funciones en plazas en
parques
habrá yo vivo en tamaulipas ahí es donde
lo hacemos y donde organizamos también
una muestra anual de cine nos hemos dado
cuenta que realmente el cine
e impacta muchísimo en la vida de las
personas hace un par de semanas
proyectamos una película que se llama
one taxi ride que es un documental sobre
la historia de un joven que al salir de
un centro nocturno en la ciudad de
mexico fue víctima de agresión sexual
por otras tres personas por tres hombres
y es un tema que está muy presente y que
las películas lo están abordando pero
nosotros no lo estamos viendo y ahí ahí
se nos está presentando y nos está
invitando a la reflexión hicimos la
función y al final hicimos un ejercicio
con la gente para que nos dijera por
escrito qué era lo que había pensado de
la película si les gustó o no les gustó
o que les hizo sentir y luego a leer lo
que me lo que me compartieron por
escrito en la encuesta una persona puso
es la manera más llegado ahora a
demostrar y evidenciar este problema
para cuando me di cuenta ya tenía
lágrimas en los ojos espero dijo otra
persona otra persona pone me identifiqué
y me conmovió muchísimo y este que me
gusta mucho lo puso una última persona
hicimos muchas encuestas pero seleccioné
como las más los que más siento que
aplican dice te abre la mente y te
sensibiliza y es que eso es lo que hacen
el cine la literatura la cultura en
general no te reta te reta a pensar a
descifrar a encontrarte en ese espejo
que puede llegar a ser un libro que
puede llegar a ser una película
no les digo que no vean cine comercial
sino que estén que tengan un
aspecto receptivo en sus vidas para
poder identificar los mensajes que allí
nos dan porque pues que es el arte que
es es difícil
e intentar definirlo yo por ejemplo me
quedo con una frase que dijo un pintor
peruano que se llama gerardo chávez que
dice que el arte es como el amor no lo
puedes explicar pero lo puedes sentir y
lo puedes hacer entonces eso es o sea
cuando alguien hace arte y conecta
contigo te cambia te cambia la
perspectiva eso fue lo que le pasó al
niño que les cantaba hace rato yo tomé
la decisión después de ese encuentro con
tantas y tantas lecturas y así eso te
abre otras perspectivas y te hace tomar
la decisión e irán a un evento que no es
cultural no tengo nada en contra de ello
espero que no es cultural te va a
entretener un rato
pero ir a algo que sea artístico y
cultural te va a cambiar la vida gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]